[Music]
and life
discoveries usually lead to four
questions
the only constant variable is the
unexpected
we can't control it
it's only when you look backwards that
you see how it was all connected
let's begin shall we
that's perfect I like to cook it's just
chemistry
you're on the verge of a major
scientific breakthrough this institution
has a reputation based on the
world-class scientists not the theories
of a pretty lab tech we have rules
you're firing me
me
just stop you're crying it's a sign of
the times
I would like to offer you a job as the
host of our cooking show are you
concussed
you are poised to become a TV star
welcome to the final show we're live in
five four three welcome viewers this is
supper at six
[Music]
do I need a catchphrase don't overthink
it never understood what that meant I
stand proudly with the overlooked War
Horse of the kitchen women and baked
potatoes
[Music]
something no one has
the platform
what you say matters politics don't
belong in the kitchen a man wants his
wife to make him a drink after a long
day at work why do you assume that his
day was longer than hers why don't you
make the drink
[Music]
you are what I treasure most in this
world not because you are pretty not
because you are smart but because you
love me and I love you
think you can't do it and you do it
anyway
your ability to change everything starts
here
children's at the table your mother
needs a moment to herself